[Music]
we're fighting a lot especially for only
being married for three months what are
y'all fighting about man the way we both
handle physical touch my wife is not a
physical touch person and i am you have
a picture of what lifetime commitment
looks like and she has a just a
different picture of what lifetime
commitment romance looks like
what is up this is john with the dr john
dolone show
the greatest mental health
wellness
marriage parenting whatever podcast you
want to call it this is the best one
ever i'm so glad that you joined us
um if you want to be on the show go to
johndaloni.com
ask and you can write us a note in the
forum and get it to us and i'm a bit
late this morning i am running around
two things one
somebody sent an email this morning
um
letting me know that i'm a satanist
actually i'm not i'm a demon working for
a satanist
and um
that i both pander to and hate women and
families so
that was awesome and
two
um i've been inspired by the great dr
peter tia's work and
his admonishment get a colonoscopy i
don't care how old you are well actually
there is an age to it right
but we wait way way way too long and
it's such a simple
colon cancer such not simple but it is a
it's something you can deal with the
earlier you catch it and it's roundly
dealt with when it's caught early and
it's a mess when it's caught late so why
not and most of our insurances will do
it for free
so i was just i signed up for one it's
pure screening there's no i'm as healthy
as uh i hope so super healthy
but they sent me this form
and here's what i have to eat this week
they call it a low residue diet oh
oh when they called me and were giving
me like the rundown of the whole thing
they're like hey you're gonna have to
eat a little residue diet and i just
stopped the nurse i was like you're
gonna stop right there that's the
grossest could you have named it
something else then like the
non-explosive just something not low
residue
anyway
glad you're with us everybody let's go
to uh i'm pretty sure uh they're gonna
edit that out let's go to brandon in st
louis what's up brandon
what's up dr d how you doing man
hey i'm doing good how are you good good
good what's up brother
hey i just had a quick question for you
hey hold on how old are you
i am 22 about to turn 23. all right man
it's like 10 to 15 years and counting
and it's gonna be colonoscopy time just
go ahead and put that on your calendar
man
all right so right what's up dude
hey um my wife and i we've been married
for a little over three months now and
i'm just wondering if you have any
advice for keeping a healthy and
sustainable marriage
and the reason i'm asking is i just feel
like we're fighting a lot especially for
only being married for three months and
i'm wanting to you know i'm wanting
things to change and just wanting to
know
if you have any advice for being a
better husband and
keeping a better relationship with my
wife what are y'all fighting about man
oh man we uh the primary things that we
fight about are uh
like
the way we both handle physical touch my
wife is not a physical touch person and
i am
and so
i feel like she's definitely like
changed um she tries to
we both try to meet in the middle but
sometimes i just kind of get upset
because
it's still different
and then uh
hold on hold on
let's dig into that real quick and i'll
go to the next one um
you phrased that as you spoke about that
as
differences in physical touch needs okay
very common in marriages but the way you
ended up
you landed there was you feel deceived
she changed on you she used to be one
way you thought you were getting one
thing and now you've got something else
tell me more about that
yeah so uh we
when we were dating
i like to hold hands and you know like
hug kind of in public and i'm not i try
not to be cringy or anything obviously
okay good don't be gropy gary the groper
not at all all right and uh she's very
hesitant to do that and i went closer to
the time we were getting married i asked
her if that was going to change when
you're married because you know we were
going to make a lifetime commitment to
each other and she
was telling me that that it was going to
be different
because
we were gonna be married and
and it's changed a little bit but i just
i don't think that it's changed as much
as i thought so i don't think that she's
that she deceived me by any chance by
any by any means but it kind of is a
little different than what i was
thinking in okay so you're trying to
work through that you you just nailed it
you have a picture of what lifetime
commitment looks like
yeah and it's that we
are high touch
high intimacy
sex all the time we hold hands in public
she
nuzzles the back of my neck you have all
these things that
this is what a lifetime commitment
romance looks like
fair right
yeah she has a different picture of what
lifetime commitment romance looks like
it might be you always have food on the
table and you always the trash just
magically disappears from inside the
house and the bed magically gets made
right so her picture of a lifetime
commitment could look very different and
that is the dance of being married right
is
is coming up with a new picture okay so
you're on to the next thing what was the
next thing
yeah uh i would say that
the biggest thing uh is probably
so there's like little things that we
could that may not necessarily need to
be a fight at all
but i think they turn into them because
we handle we both have
we both handle angry um angerness
different so if i'm angry about
something then you've kind of talked
about like you use silence as a weapon
that's how i do it is i'm just kind of
turned quiet and kind of shut myself off
whereas my wife will
sort of rage out and so both are wrong
uh and i definitely can do better now
i don't think both are wrong both are
just
are
maybe the situation with which they hurt
somebody else or when they are applied
to somebody else right i i'm a guy that
defaults to silence
until i a switch flips that's what my
wife calls it
and
um man that's a good thing i don't say
stupid things i've never hit any you
know i mean i don't i'm not a violent
guy
um and so silence is a great default
network it's when i use silence
to get my way
that's when i'm i'm miss using or
sometimes exploding like will you please
just hear me or i'm so frustrated
um man i totally get that it's when it
you do that at somebody and you hurt
somebody right so i don't i don't want
to lionize those things let me let me
back up a little bit here
um
you're 22 how old is she
she is about 21.
y'all are really young why'd you get
married so young
we've been dating for a few uh we've
been dating for a little over two years
about almost three okay and we we waited
we wanted to get married right after he
graduated just because
living situation and we felt kind we
wanted to get but we wanted to figure
things out as we grew up together
instead of trying to do it separately
and then coming back you know coming
together after a while doing that cool
so let me tell you a story like so when
i first got married um i remember the
time my wife i don't know if i've
mentioned this on the show or not i i
remember time my wife was
next to me in the bathroom brushing her
teeth
and
i remember she took her toothbrush and
then she put toothpaste on the
toothbrush and because she's a serial
killer she shoved it directly into her
mouth and just started brushing her
teeth
and i remember looking at her and i said
you're doing that wrong
to it she's wise and she was like i
don't know this is a thing that you can
do wrong
um enlighten me obi-wan and i said well
the way you're supposed to do it is
you're supposed to put toothpaste on the
tooth
brush and then put it under the water
first and then put it in your mouth
weirdo
and someone who doesn't hate babies
and so
we both walked into our marriage with
just a picture of here's how you brush
teeth right
both of you guys are dealing with
i thought my life was going to continue
as is i was just going to have my
husband and wife move into my my life
and so what you're here what you're
experiencing a super normal please don't
overreact to it okay you probably feel
trapped you probably feel buried up to
your neck right like what have i done
have you had those thoughts
oh yeah
i wish you would just come in and say we
shouldn't have done this and she would
just leave like i wish i could like
there's just this
i get it and then if you're like most
not most
like many
um you have thoughts and then you get
really upset that you had those thoughts
like you're some kind of bad guy right
you're not okay
what you have is two people trying to
live
lives in their own lane and drag the
other person over into their lane
because this is the way life is gonna be
and what you haven't done yet and this
is what getting married at 28 29 or 30
will give you
is some tools to say
we are no long are the lives we led are
over
they do not exist anymore
we now have to in real time we have to
change the oil on this car while it's
driving we got to decide to build
something new together and that's a
totally different proposition
and so the picture you had up about what
what committed love is going to look
like in her picture does neither of
those matter
now what matters is here's a paint brush
here's a paint brush here's some paint
let's paint something new together let's
figure something else out
and that starts with a conversation that
if you can get this done at 22 you will
you'll have the greatest marriage of
anybody i've ever met
and that is a cyclical
recursive like back and forth all the
time
every two months every three months
every quarter
we're gonna have a conversation where we
write it down what are your needs in
this season
we're both trying something new
how can i
best meet your needs even if it's gonna
make me uncomfortable and i know it's
not very popular right now because it's
supposed to be like no if it doesn't
make you uncomfortable you go do you bro
that's all stupid no relationships last
with that sort of infantile mentality
what you need is to say hey what can i
do
tell me
here's what i need i need physical touch
i need
sexual intimacy i need you to pick up
your underwear i need you to help make
the bed
and then here's what you can control on
that you
so when somebody calls and says hey how
do i fix my marriage how to
strengthen yourself
decide i'm gonna be the best freaking
husband who's ever lived
by meeting needs and by the way she's
got to participate too this becomes a
very one-sided trip if she's like forget
you dude i'm not i'm not helping meet
your needs you weirdo
um
but you have to say these things out
loud and these are best done like not in
a fight
the little picky fights you're talking
about those are proxy wars that's the
that's you have no margin you have no
emotional margin you probably aren't
sleeping that well your diet's probably
all gone to hell you're just
everything's a mess right now you've
been married three months
and then the little there's just no
margin to absorb the the
where's the cup i thought you put it
over there and now
now we're in this fight for no reason
right
so
it's you've heard me say this so many
times i wish i could come up with
something new i was thinking about this
morning in the gym like i need to come
up with some new material
but really what y'all need to do is go
decide like hey
i want to take you out we're three
months in
and
we've hit some bumps and some rocks and
some like just some normal growing pains
let's make something awesome and let's
decide what that's going to look like
and then we're going to practice it as
we move forward
and by the way one thing i want to give
you brandon
every time you get
start to get mad or frustrated or sad
or loud or angry
stop
say nothing okay
will you do that
absolutely yeah absolutely i'd love to
hear you learn at age 22 to say
i'm gonna need a minute
i'll be right back
you are you're fine
i'm
i have
my insides have set on fire and i need a
minute
and um let me go for a walk real quick
let me go do 40 push-ups outside let me
go write something down and then i'll be
back
give me an hour give me 45 minutes or
whatever and if you can start that right
now creating a gap between your feeling
and then what you say or what you do or
getting angry
um
you're gonna have a lot of peace in your
home especially if your wife
joins along with you are these things
possible if you if you took her out and
said hey can we just like
all right three months in
i'm trying to force you to live in my
world and i feel like i'm getting
dragged into your world and what we need
to do is create our world what would
that even look like
could you start there
yeah would she be in on that
yeah she'd she'd be in she's
she's awesome love her to death
i'd say that something else that kind of
happens to
uh and she knows this too and um
and so i would say that when we get in a
fight it could be something really small
when she gets really upset and i i
you know have done this before and i try
my best not to do it and i don't think
i've done it when we've been married
but she'll lash out and she'll say some
like super hateful things and she'll
always apologize after she says them
give me an example
um
so
when
she'll get upset about something or will
get upset and then one of the things
that she does is if it escalates she'll
say something like i hate you i hate you
or we should have never gotten married
and she she so sh so a little bit after
that you know i tell her that really
really makes me mad and you told me last
time you weren't going to say that again
but at the same time i feel like i
really can't i i know that she needs to
take responsibility for actions as i do
too but she grew up in a home where it
was everybody said that
um everybody said that they hated each
other parents
didn't show their love to her and it was
it's sad so i'm trying to keep my
my head up when that stuff happens but
it just makes me really upset sure i
divorce is never on the table sure and
so okay let me hop in here here here's
your path forward okay
number one she cannot make you mad
that's a choice you make
okay okay
um and here's why that's important
it's very important outside of the heat
of battle outside of the heat of a
moment um
you know what i'm gonna take back what i
said my wife can make me mad i've given
her permission to do that um so i'm
gonna take that back
you get to choose your response
very few people my boss can't make me
mad but i just don't give people that i
don't give them that i've worked for a
decade to decouple myself from other
people but i give my wife permission to
make me mad um i love her i
she gets permission to speak in my life
i have the choice on how i respond to
that how i act
here's an important thing you all need
in your marriage
is really firm boundaries so you respond
when she says i hate you
your response i wish we never got
married
you're responsive that really makes me
mad you've just poured gasoline on a
fire
right
good point in a non-fight when you're
out to breakfast you're out to lunch and
you're figuring out like all right how
are we going to build this thing
you each get to make rules
and one of the rules for you one of your
boundaries is
if you say that you hate me
you are telling me that you want to end
the conversation and you want me to walk
away because that's what i'm choosing to
do
i will choose to leave the conversation
a hundred percent of the time you tell
me you hate me
every time
and so she's not um she will learn in
short order
that her husband has very strong
boundaries and then he will opt out
quietly with respect and i'm gonna walk
away
and by the way i don't care about her
childhood when it comes to that kind of
crap that is infantile acting like a
child she's got to stop that
okay it's destructive and
again i wish she'd gotten a better model
when she was a kid she didn't
and so she's got to stop
and that's got to be
you know she's going to practice
stopping that's all she knows she's 21.
um she's got a lot of maturity that
she's got to undergo in the next five 10
15 20 years or in my case 30 40 50 years
um
that's a no-go
absolutely no-go but that starts with
you saying i will not accept you telling
me that you hate me
i will choose to lead that conversation
you see what i'm saying your response
any response after that is i'm choosing
to punch back and why right it's it's
all when she crosses over there
you're fighting a generational fight
right she's fighting her parents she's
fighting their parents this has nothing
to do with you step out
right right
and at some point if she wants to solve
the actual challenge that's before you
if she wants to get closer to you become
more intimate with you
um
she will know i'm not going to throw
that grenade because that grenade is her
choosing i don't want you in my in my
space anymore
and um that's her choosing to be a child
a hurtful child
uh just aside listeners don't say you
hate people don't say you hate your
spouse or your kids don't say you want a
divorce
don't say we never should take that crap
off the table you're here you've done it
you did it okay
it's about what are we gonna do next
brandon
i've said this a thousand times i'll say
it a million times more until they
cancel the show which who knows i feel
like i'm always one go away
you can't live your life and drag her
into yours and she can't live her life
and drag you into hers you'll have to
decide
that the lives y'all were living are
over they're over
who are we gonna be together
we can both still have our dreams we can
both still have our goals and our lives
but they are now one they are not
together we're gonna build something
together moving forward and you each get
to state along that journey what your
needs are by the way your needs will
change and you both get to state what
the boundaries are you can't talk to me
like that i don't like to touch in these
situations
fill in the blank every couple makes
their own rules as they go
but you gotta state them out loud
you can do this brandon call me back in
about six months let me know how things
are going i'm excited for you guys we'll
be right back
hey delony here and i've got a word from
our sponsor from betterhelp i've been on
the giving and receiving end of therapy
for years
when i was spinning out like a decade
ago with wild anxiety i had a moment
that light bulb moment that i knew i had
to do something different i knew i had
to change something probably a lot of
somethings right but i found myself
without the tools for taking the next
step
and when you're facing problems or
challenges in life it's way too easy to
get stuck in that anxious spiral of doom
i've been there
but when you learn how to stop that
cycle and start taking ownership of your
life that's when you're free
and that's what therapy can help you do
it gives you the tools you need to do
the problem solving in your own life and
that's why i love better help better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours
if you're ready to get the tools that
you need to deal with the curveball's
life's thrown at you therapy can help
visit betterhelp.com
delony to get 10 off your first month
that's betterhelp.com
deloney
all right we're back jack crackerjack
let's go to cynthia and theo nix arizona
what's up cynthia
hello how you doing i'm good how about
you
i'm okay
all right hey that's as good as we can
do sometimes right what's up yes
so
my question is i'm having trouble with
um my daughter so
a quick recap when she was 14 um
she was going on social media created an
instagram account behind my back because
i already told her she could not have
any social media she was using other
people's phones like family members they
thought that she was playing games but
yet she created this account
talking to some stranger boy
who i think was like an older man type
thing she was
sending inappropriate um
pictures to him
he they would call each other talk on
the phone
um he would never show his face only she
would show her face so that's why i
think it was like an older man what kind
of inappropriate photos was she sending
of herself
like topless photos or
essential photos
as a 14 year old
as a 14 year old yes so when um we
caught that took all the phones um told
everybody hey she cannot go on anybody's
phone and she needs to call a family
member you have to dial the phone for
her
so i thought that was cleared now when
she's 15 um code would happen they sent
um the children home with laptop
computers
she started going on the zoom chat rooms
with
you know strangers again
so again took her phone away
i mean took the computer away like we
would have to like okay if you've got to
do school work you got to be around
somebody
so now she's about to be 16 we um
started a new school fresh start
we're telling her like you know what you
cannot be on these
sites anymore we're gonna give you back
your phone because now you're about to
be 16.
okay we're going to start this rush four
days into
school
you're back
i call her um i went in her room
and i saw like the laptop underneath her
her blanket when i opened it up she's
chatting again with random people saying
i love you they're boyfriend and
girlfriend i'm like
they're boyfriend and girlfriend i'm
like why are you telling us i was like
who is this person i don't know i just
went to this chat room i'm like how do
you get this chat room because when i
tell you to open it up you never know
the password but now all of a sudden you
remember it so i'm just like i don't
know what to do like i don't know why
she needs
to keep chatting with these boys these
strangers i don't know what she's
looking for what she needs
i'm asking why she does it i don't know
he says she wants friends you just move
you know you just um started this new
school so you start you have friends why
are you always trying to build
relationships online so i don't know
what to do we tried counseling
that was like
she wasn't participating in she said she
doesn't need it
it was like
nothing there was no good outcome from
counselors so i don't know what else to
do
man
there's so much
here um
yeah
there is and then there's not okay
16 year olds are very smart
and they're very capable
um 15 year olds i've been around some
extremely mature 14 year olds that are
impressive smart fun hilarious
um i was a high school coach and i
coached freshmen and sophomores and they
were awesome i loved being around them
they're they're great they made me laugh
and they're children
they're children
and
they don't have the emotional regulatory
capacity in many cases
to
to
detach from the need to be seen
to be
attached from a need to be heard and or
at least felt like they're heard to be
seen as special
so
what is happening in your home that this
is where she goes to get that stuff
um
so her father is not in her life okay um
he's been well that's about what i need
to know right there that's about yeah
right there okay he's been in and out of
her life um he's been um incarcerated
he's incarcerated now so
they talk here and there like when she
wants to talk to him she'll tell me and
i'll make a visit but it's not often so
she needs she's
again i'm i'm making a lot of leaps here
without talking to her and spending some
time with her but
it's not a surprise to me that she is
her sweet little 14 15 16 year old brain
is wondering every single day
what was so bad about me that dad left
what did i do
and then somebody on an anonymous chat
room says
i'll tell you that you're beautiful
i'll show up and tell you that you have
value
just take your shirt off
and
once that switch gets flipped now we're
in a whole different ball game
because there's a natural
physiological arc to this that gets
circumvented which is why we keep adult
predators away from kids
because once the switch is flipped on
now you've got a whole different ball of
wax dealing with kids who've been
sexualized
and so asking what are you doing
this is this is primal this is in her
soul
i will find some man that will tell me
that i'm gut value and that i'm
beautiful and that i'm not worthless
because the one guy that was supposed to
be here left me
and she's going to spend a long long
time trying to bridge that gap
okay
that's an oversimplified explanation i'm
sure there's more complexity to it in
particular pear tree here's the rub
none of that matters
what matters is
let's pretend there was like an arcade
and you dropped your daughter off this
arcade with some regularity just a cool
place to hang out and then she told you
hey there's strange men hitting on me
there and they come and rub my shoulders
and they want me to take my shirt off
and they say nice things about me just
feels
and then you're like well
i don't think i'm gonna keep dropping
you off there
and then she sneaks out you find out
she's sneaking out and she's going there
and you go get her
when she turns 16 for her birthday would
you then just take her back and be like
all right make good choices
you
no
never let her go back
you'd call the cops you you would scorch
earth
and for some reason when it comes to
the internet and computers
we think those are different things and
i would say they are different in that
there's way more predators online than
there are in real life
and what i'll tell you is i've just been
a part of too many investigations over
the past 17 18 19 years working in
colleges with high school and college
kids
that have oh man it just it's got i've
got a rise in me okay
save your daughter
is what i'm telling you
she's begging you save your daughter
be the adult that doesn't leave her
okay what does that mean
that means i'm going to the school
and saying my kid will not participate
in your laptop program because you have
not provided us any sort of safety
mechanisms that keep kids from getting
into
chat rooms with adult sexual predators
that keep them off the internet that
outside of school stuff and i don't know
how to solve that i don't work i'm not a
programmer that's y'all's problem
right my math textbook didn't have a
special portal that someone would
sexually abuse me when i was a kid
your child does
so as far as i'm concerned you're going
to give my kid alternative assignments
until y'all figure out how to keep
predators out of my home
okay you see what i'm saying
yes
i reject it because they are failing you
and i would make it pretty direct
and like here's some printouts of the
chats of that my daughter's undergoing
on your school device
this also may mean that in your home
you have to get rid of the internet
and thank god that would be annoying and
uncomfortable
and expensive and just frustrating all
the time
you mean you got to go back to getting
dvds at the library yep
but we're talking about your daughter
of course
we're talking about two more years
and so many times i hear parents are
like i would do anything for my kid i
turn off the internet
i'm not gonna take away their cell phone
do it
do anything
here's one more thing
sending her to counseling
about her
sexting
is not the way to go about that
okay
taking her to counseling with you
because you are looking to heal
and become a stronger
um
woman and a stronger mother
after her husband after her father left
you all together
and you're learning some new skills
that's how you do that
okay because if you take her somewhere
and drop her off and say something's
wrong with you they're going to fix it
that's that's the declaration of war for
a 15 16 year old bring it then okay
right
if it's hey i realized that dad screwed
us both left
and i um
i'll learn how to love you better
and so i'm not asking you are going to
be a part of that you can sit there in
the room and not say anything but you're
going to be a part of it
um that's a whole different ballgame and
then you know what she gets to see she
gets to see mom cry she gets to see mom
be sad she gets to see mom
be confused
and then she doesn't feel so crazy
anymore
okay but be the only adult in this young
girl's life that will say i'm not
leaving you and i'm standing up and
dude i absolutely know cynthia
that when you take away all this stuff
and put her on an island
it is gonna be it's gonna be hell on
earth in your home i know that
okay
it's also going to be hell on earth when
she comes home pregnant
it's going to be hell on earth when she
comes home and says mom i've got fill in
the blank with stis it's going to be
hell on earth when she when you get a
call from a police department saying hey
we found a bunch of nude photos of your
daughter on some guy's computer
you're just picking your hell on earth
and i'd rather pick the relational one
right because there's light on the other
side of that one
i have a quick question so with her
father being incarcerated
i feel like
i will
i feel like okay that's her father still
they should have a relationship but i
just feel like it's just toxic because
you pick and choose when you want to
call
your your children either he's going to
be either he's going to be consistent
or he is opting out of his daughter's
life
again okay
right even if even if she acts to speak
with him she can let's write letters
okay
okay
okay
um
i need some more guidance on that i have
a strong bent and my my opinion on that
it may not be the right thing i'd want
to talk to someone who's an expert in
those type of relationships
what i do know sitting here is that
inconsistency from adults to children
makes children go crazy
because they think they're the reason
there's inconsistency
right or when dad skips uh skips uh some
sort of meeting or some sort of phone
call or some sort of face time they
assume huh
must have been something else more
important than me
and the kid doesn't know that dad's in
solitary or that they just did a
lockdown and they took away all the
privileges kid doesn't know that
right um so the kid just absorbs it all
and makes it their fault
and so
letters can always be written
there can always and you can also hold a
letter right you can touch it and you
can read it again and you can read it
again and you can read it again
but if dad's playing games i'm not
having that okay
that's how i feel but then i get like
i get
you know like torn well
i don't want the courts like he's is he
gonna take me to court and make this
ugly but i'm like you probably wouldn't
because he's listening
he's made it ugly
you're trying you're trying to polish a
turd it's a mess there's not a way to
make this not not ugly
okay right he left y'all whatever he did
he left you heinrich
and if he wants to take you to court
then okay i'll go to court then
okay
um i think this is a conversation best
had with your counselor that you're
gonna get with you and your daughter
okay okay and letting her know this is
mostly for you but you she's coming
along with you because your counselor is
gonna know you and know her and be able
to say hey i think we need to stop the
calls
often in these moments i do know this
time around the calls escalates
behavioral issues with kids especially
teenagers
to call time right after the call with
dad escalation time right before the
call escalation dad misses a call
escalation i'm talking about dad in jail
or dad who's divorced who just is kind
of flaky
and so at some point
i'm not gonna let this person who is
their biological father but they are is
not daddy
i'm not gonna let this person
continue to throw grenades inside my
house at some point i'm the parent i
gotta draw boundaries similar to this
electronic mess okay
moms and dads you've heard me if you're
listening to show for five seconds
you've heard me and i'll say it again
and i'll say it again and i'll say it
again
at some point we have to stand up in our
local schools and stand up in our local
communities and say enough is enough
with the electronics as a
taxpayer
the pedagogical value is just
dismal the roi on the amount of money
we're spending in public schools and
local schools private schools i don't
care just to say look what we have look
what we have look what we have
when it comes to technological
advancements
you can see the state of teachers may i
just go off we got to stop we have to
stop we have to stop
somebody has to fight for their kids
please let it be you
please let it be you we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless homebuyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process
you need folks like my friends at
churchill mortgage churchill is a ramsey
trusted provider that's been helping
people with their home mortgages for
decades and their home buyer edge
program will help you skip a bunch of
the stress here's how it works apply to
become a churchill certified home buyer
and cap your interest rate for 90 days
then you'll get a 5 000 seller guarantee
to help your offer stand out so go ahead
take a deep breath because churchill has
your back check them out at
churchillmortgage.com
and get the homebuyer edge today this is
a paid advertisement in mls id 1591 nmls
consumeraccess.org equal housing lender
1749 mallory lane suite 100 brentwood
tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and are not available in
all states or locations
all right we're back let's go to lynn in
sioux falls south dakota what's up lynn
uh not much how about yourself i'm doing
all right i'm doing all right
so what's up lady how can i help
um okay so
um i'll just give a little backstory
first so my daughter was born in january
of this past year so she's seven months
um when she was born they noticed she
had a lot of fluids build up in her
um
kind of below her knee and her feet and
her labia a little bit as well
um so at first they thought maybe it's
just because she was cramped in the
birthing
position for so long but then it didn't
go away so we met with a geneticist and
they
decided to do two different genetic
tests on her anyway those both came back
negative so they decided to do a whole
exome sequencing on
my daughter myself and my husband and
then
um in june the results came in and that
we found out that she has milroy's
disease so
yeah
i know so it's a really rare medical
condition they the genetic doctor we
have
been seeing told us that there's less
than 200 cases or excuse me 300 cases
like
in medical literature it's just so rare
but um the biggest thing that comes with
that is just lymphedema right how is her
lymphedema is it is she draining well or
she's starting to have sores on her feet
how is how is it
um
you know it's really well managed we
have a really good lymphedema therapist
good she was born in a really great
hospital um they caught it right away so
yeah she's been doing compression since
she was born we've
um we actually have been to the
children's hospital of philadelphia i
mean we've been a lot of good places so
it's under very well
like it's being managed very well she
doesn't have she hasn't developed sores
on her feet or anything yet
um
not any current ones we've dealt with
that a little bit as of now it's been
all good
um she just had her first round of
cellulitis yeah but that's over with now
but that's kind of the biggest
risk factor with lymphedema is the
cellulitis but
um what about mobility
um her mobility is really good really
good she's scooting around
yeah she's a stinker she's standing on
stuff i mean her mobility but yeah like
i said we've been working with a really
good lymphedema therapist and a physical
therapist and they've been watching that
the whole way so yeah she's right on
track of where she should be so cool all
right so how can i help by the way
everybody listen miller's disease is a
very very like she said very very rare
um just a dysfunction of the lymphatic
system and i don't know enough about it
to talk with any sort of eloquence about
it but
um
we have fluids drainage systems in our
bodies that things get expelled um via
urine throw our bowels like that it's
just part of our system and
um this very rare disease
it you can get you can get over enlarged
feet legs sometimes it's one leg
sometimes it's both feet which is what
does she have in both feet
yeah she has it in both feet both legs
and then um it's in her hands um and
arms slightly as well not to the point
yet where she has to wear compression
garments but yeah mainly in
both her legs and then her right leg is
actually a little bit worse than her
left so okay all right okay so
you are here
how can i help
so yeah my question is um
if i'm trying to make it as much as one
question as possible but there's kind of
a couple little parts to it so how do we
teach her how important it is as she
gets older to
um basically self-manage
her lymphedema and how do we
best
like
just really imprint it on her heart that
she's just so beautiful and then as my
as her mom i am the carrier of it i have
the disease as well i have no symptoms
which yeah 10 to 15 percent of people
that have it have no symptoms i have no
symptoms how do i deal with the guilt
um
of
yeah giving that to her
all let me i'm writing myself a note
here um
[Music]
um
all of this starts with that
okay
you have to be very direct with yourself
are you married
yes yep okay um
you like who you're married to
he's a good guy yeah he's good he's he's
he's the positive i'm the worrier so
you have to
be very direct with yourself and with
him
and your adult community
about dealing with your guilt
okay okay
you know as much as i do that you didn't
cause this you didn't do this and it was
a
wild genetic
throne of dart in the dark and it hit
the bullseye
right
and so um
if your daughter sees you once
when you look at her
she'll internalize that
if your daughter sees you cry or to
somehow harbor guilt this is my fault i
can't believe i did this
um
children will make that disconnection
their fault and she'll try to solve it
in a million different ways
so the greatest gift out of the gate you
can give this little girl
is to make peace with yourself and make
peace with your body
and i also know that's a tall order okay
i'm not saying that's easy
um it's a similar conversation i have to
people who accidentally hit their kid
with a car or who hurt their child or
accidentally drop you know whatever the
thing happens to be
it's making
uh making peace
not making it go away not but making
peace this happened okay
and i have permission to be sad i'm
gonna do that with my counselor i'm
gonna do that with my husband i'm gonna
do it with my friends
and then i'm gonna be in this moment and
i'm gonna go about being the best
freaking mom who's ever lived which i'm
pretty sure you are
cool
yep yeah okay
so step number one we're gonna deal with
our anxiousness and we're gonna deal
with our guilt
she is not going to do this because
that's not her job right
okay
so when it comes to teach a kid
self-advocacy how to stand up for
yourself how to do your things here's
where these get hard i've been working
with students with young people with
special needs for most of my
professional career
here's where this is challenging is
a
there's just a convenience it'd just be
so much faster i would put your
compression socks for you on for you so
we can get to this stupid restaurant
and what we do over time is we start to
deny our kids whether they have special
needs or exceptionalities or they're
just a regular old square in the middle
of the bell curve kit
we rob them of struggle
and when we rob kids of struggle we rob
them of growth and development and
resilience
so it's stealing from our kids
for a kid with milroy's disease it's
gonna be
harder
it just is
because if she has to put on
compression gloves and compression socks
every morning
gosh i think just getting my kid to find
socks makes me want to set my hair on
fire sometimes
and then like i
i was cleaning the garage are you any
random socks i found i mean so just
kidding with socks issues right
yeah yours is going to be challenging
and so
your plan now is
it's going to take us 50 minutes to get
ready to go to church or to get ready to
go to the out to eat when it would
normally would have taken us 10 minutes
15 minutes it's gonna take some time
but i'm not gonna rob my child of that
struggle
and they're gonna learn self-advocacy
another thing in a restaurant when they
bring our food
i don't say thank you for the whole
table
my kids say thank you for their
individual plates
i'm teaching them they have a role to
play in gratitude
that also so similarly if your child
needs something needs a wheelchair and
not when they're six by the way but when
they're 10 when they're 12 when they're
14 and you're at the airport you can
take her up to the counter holding her
hand
and say
tell this gentleman what you need
and she will say i need a
someone to push me from here to the gate
please
and they will bend down and look her in
the eye and say i got you
and she will learn the beauty of mom's
right here with me
and i just spoke my needs and this
awesome guy is going to make it happen
for me
see what i'm saying
yeah
that makes it so much easier for you
just to leave her with dad you run up
there and grab say hey my kids needs a
wheelchair in the bed gotcha so much
easier
that means we have to go to the airport
30 minutes early right see what i'm
saying
yeah so yeah just
we're going to slowly incorporate her
into her own
life
right yeah
and that brings me to this
it's gonna sound counter-intuitive okay
okay we're gonna be very direct
about what she has
might even show her that your leg is
different than her legs
that she's got exceptionalities
we're gonna call it out and we're not
gonna hide it
okay because kids feel when we hide
things
and then they feel even more of a big
giant red light bulb
in their life than they already do
we're gonna focus on what we're gonna do
not what we can't do
and man
um
we're gonna have hard seasons and low
times and good seasons and good times
and we're gonna make the best childhood
we can move them forward
yeah
so i just made it so easy right go go go
go get them later i'm just like i'm just
taking it all um yeah and kind of um
yeah i guess yeah another thing that i
just kind of worry about a little bit is
you know like
you know she'll never be able to get a
pedicure and not worry about that but
you know should not be able to get a
pedicure should probably never be able
to wear
flip-flops and
you know when she wears shorts you know
i'm sure she's gonna want to it's you
know it gets warm i just don't want her
to feel like the odd one out because
she's got these big
you know compression garments they just
never want her to feel like
she's not perfect you know the way she
is you know and i don't there's a couple
things here
don't ever make her carry your baggage
yeah here's what i mean by that
my kid is growing up in a world where
there's an african-american president
my kids growing up in a world where
social issues are different where
there's not a table at his school that
just has people who listen to country
music at it and then another one that
listens to hip-hop and another one
listens to heavy metal like my high
school did
right
and so when i ask him where do you sit
he's like i don't know i just sit around
my head instantly goes to panic
if you're not at the right table dude
things go sideways for you he has a
different world that's not his
experience and so you have understanding
of what it's like to
put on shorts
and not have people look at you she
won't have to that would be her whole
world will be her legs
yeah right and so yeah she's gonna know
that and we're gonna call it out
we're gonna call it out let's put on
some shorts and
um put on your special socks
and then we're gonna go about our day
and if people look and ask you can say
with her chin held up i've got milroy's
this means my body doesn't drain fluid
good you want to go play
yeah
you see what i'm saying and all the
other stuff doesn't come now make no
mistake middle school will be hell
high school will be tough right we know
that
yeah we know that
and
we can preventatively mourn that and
slip into this low-level dysthymia this
little level depression that just runs
our life
or we can just go reckless with joy and
good times and figuring this thing out
as we go and deal with the heavy when it
gets heavy
yeah makes sense and i yeah i totally
agree yeah
she's going to feel beautiful if you
treat her beautifully
yeah
she is going to feel odd and scary if
you flinch when you hold her
yeah which yeah that's not how it is now
and you know like we love her and i just
yeah i don't yeah oh
middle school's gonna be awesome middle
school's gonna yeah people are gonna ask
her but then she's gonna find her gang
right she's gonna fall in with her
people
and they're gonna do their thing
and then there's probably gonna be some
people who are hyper protective of her i
had a couple of friends like that but i
was hyper i still i'm hyper protective
of them
right and they're because they're in my
gang
they're my they're on my team right and
she'll find that but
so it's gonna be both end
and by then you will have she she will
have five 10
12 years of advocacy
of pulling on her own socks even though
it takes forever of having hard
conversations of asking for support when
she needs it
and
she's going to be able to just to
she's going to it'll hurt but she's
going to be able to move past that
nonsense see what i'm saying yeah
yes yes maybe move past it later on
being 12 just as hard being 12 right
yeah um
but we're not going to hide our our
daughter she's beautiful
yeah we're not going to hide her and
we're not going to pre-grieve things
that haven't come yet we're going to
live our life as as we are and there's
also my guess is some pretty
extraordinary medical advancements that
are on the way right
yeah yeah even from
20 years ago it sounds like there's a
lot of
you know
you know new things and good things
absolutely so let's keep our heads up
and when we get sad we're gonna go to
adults with that sadness and we're not
gonna we're not gonna throw things that
our kids have to carry for us
and we're gonna be honest and not hide
anything this is what this is you're
just shorter than the other kids
um
you
you suffer from milroy's you're not
going to wear flip-flops
what would flip-flops be like they're
fine but you can't run in them
yeah
and plus
uh
i i've never got a pedicure lynn and my
life's relatively fine
i would feel sorry for my getting a
pedicure for me would be like dumb and
dumber it would not be pleasant for
anybody doing my
pedicure um i know that's something dumb
but no no but but but it's an experience
that mom wants to have with it with her
daughter
yeah okay i mean this brings me to the
last thing i'm gonna tell you then i'll
let you go okay
okay
when you find out you are pregnant
the picture machine started
and when you found out you're having a
little girl
you started thinking about what it's
going to be like when she brings some
idiot home from college
you started thinking about what
thanksgiving was going to be like
you thought about the wedding you
thought about all that stuff because
you're normal and you love your kid
and then she was born
and then there was some challenges and
there was a testing and more testing and
more doctor visits and more testing then
they sat you down and said hey actually
there's this genetic thing
and all of those pictures have blown up
but what most of us do is we go about
our day comparing our reality with those
pictures that we made up before we even
had all the details
and it's that energy expenditure that
wears this out
and so the energy is must much better
spent moving forward
yeah i had a picture man of what this is
going to look like it's not going to
happen it's going to be different
like mother duck i'm going to take her
to get pedicures every saturday honey
you got to make way more money because
we're doing this to get it's not going
to happen
so what is going to happen that becomes
oh man every sunday
we're going to the beach we're going to
the water we're going swimming we're
going to whatever the thing is
the mother daughter time will still be
right so you see what i'm saying it's
just adjusting that picture
yes and it's so hard
i would recommend
writing a letter
to that old picture here's what i
thought was going to happen
you may even start a journal that she's
going to be able to read someday
but things get heavy
and she'll know just how much mom loved
her
okay
but i can do that but writing something
down that says
i had this picture i thought we were
gonna get a bunch of uh
pedicures together i thought we were i
just had pictures of us running in the
beach and our flip-flops and having cute
toes and i just said the word cute toes
and so my brain malfunctioned a bit but
i had this thing and it's not gonna
happen so now what now
what most of us spend so much energy
myself included lin going back and
trying to edit sentences that have
already been written they've got
exclamation points or periods at the end
of them they're over and i keep going
back i wish i hadn't said that i wish i
hadn't done that i wish this could be
different i wish my kids could i wish me
and my wife could
they're over
it's over
the only thing i can affect
is what's gonna happen moving forward
i thought this was gonna be that way
it's not
so now it's gonna be like this
and the one thing in the world i can
choose that i get to own
is that gap
between what is reality and what could
be
i get to choose what going forward looks
like
and you can too
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
all right as we wrap up today's show
thanks for being with us
i don't know much about this band is
this why you have a big dragon tattoo on
the back of your neck
imagine dragons i imagine dragons
it felt like the song fit the email
we discussed earlier oh yeah because i'm
a demon working for a satanist
the song is called demons and it goes
like this when the days are cold and the
cards all fold and the saints we see are
all made of gold when your dreams all
fall
and the ones we hail our dreams all fail
and the ones we hail are the worst of
all and the bloods run stale i want to
hide the truth i want to shelter you but
the beast inside there's nowhere to hide
what is this song
don't want to let you down
demons
are
we'll see you soon